From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》节目，我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。
All right, you're going to flip your collar up. All right, that's going to look real nice, don't you think? Going to look nice?
好了，你要把衣领竖起来。对了，这样看起来真的很不错，你不觉得吗？看起来不错吧？
Looks good.
看起来很好。
Looking sharp.
看起来很精神。
The groom's ready. The bride's ready. They have never kissed, not even one time. She only asked him to marry her two weeks ago. In they march-- flower girls, three bridesmaids, three groomsmen, the grey-haired pastor who's done this dozens of times, the groom, who has known the bride since fifth grade, and finally the bride. They both just graduated from high school this month. We're in Davenport, Iowa.
新郎准备好了，新娘也准备好了。他们甚至一次都没有亲吻过。两周前，她才刚刚向他求婚。他们走入礼堂——花童、三位伴娘、三位伴郎，还有那位已经主持过几十次婚礼、头发花白的牧师，以及从五年级就认识新娘的新郎，最后是新娘本人。他们俩这个月才刚刚高中毕业。我们现在在爱荷华州的达文波特。
Our guests may be seated. A truly blessed, happy occasion brings us here. I hope that your hearts are happy.
请各位来宾入座。一个真正受祝福、快乐的时刻让我们聚在这里。希望你们的心情也是愉快的。
All of this is fake. Absolutely, completely fake, every single part of it. We're in a home for elderly people with Alzheimer's and the staff is staging a phony wedding because, well, it makes the residents feel good. They enjoy picking out hats and jewelry to wear. They enjoy talking about their own weddings, those who still remember them. They have all sorts of confusions and perceptual problems and they cannot tell that it is fake.
这一切都是假的。彻头彻尾的虚构，每一个环节都是。我们现在所在的地方是一家阿尔茨海默症老人护理院，工作人员正在筹办一场假婚礼，因为，好吧，这能让住户们感到快乐。他们喜欢挑选要戴的帽子和首饰。那些还记得自己婚礼的人，喜欢谈论他们当年的婚礼。他们有各种认知和感知方面的障碍，无法分辨出这是假的。
--At a wedding. We all love a wedding, don't we? Ashley William Poust--
——在婚礼上。我们都喜欢婚礼，不是吗？阿什利·威廉·波斯特——
Over on the side, two old women whisper excitedly about the bride's dress. A woman in the first row cries. There are three men who stare straight ahead in space, not registering anything. But nearly everybody else is much more bright-eyed and engaged than unusual, the caretakers all say. This is Judy Rader.
在旁边，两位老妇人兴奋地低声谈论着新娘的礼服。第一排的一位女士哭了。有三位男士直勾勾地盯着前方，仿佛什么也没察觉。但护理人员说，几乎其他所有人都比平时眼神更明亮、更投入。这是朱迪·雷德。
It's amazing. All these people are patients and usually can't focus on the same thing at the same time.
太神奇了。所有这些人都是患者，通常很难同时专注于同一件事。
Do you solemnly declare--
你是否郑重宣告——
They're looking at the minister which again, they're focusing on the person that's delivering the speech, which oftentimes isn't.
他们都在看着牧师，再次强调，他们专注于正在发言的人，而这通常是做不到的。
In fact, it all looks real enough-- the pastor's homily, the vows, the rings. The only signs that this is a complete sham are that the bride barely looks at the groom. When she delivers her vows, she fixes her eyes on the pastor. The couple does not hold hands.
事实上，这一切看起来足够真实——牧师的布道、誓言、交换戒指。唯一能看出这是场闹剧的迹象是新娘几乎不看新郎。当她宣读誓言时，她的目光一直盯着牧师。这对新人也没有牵手。
You may now kiss the bride and there's no limits.
现在你可以亲吻新娘了，而且没有任何限制。
And when they kiss, these two friends-- just friends-- from high school, go in once for a quick peck and then, suspecting that that was not convincing enough, they quickly kiss a second time.
当他们亲吻时，这两个来自高中的朋友——只是朋友——先是快速地亲了一下，然后觉得这样不够有说服力，于是又赶紧亲了第二次。
We don't consider it lying. We consider it organizing special moments for them. Because Alzheimer residents have short-term memory loss. So their special moments are sometimes all they have.
我们不认为这是撒谎。我们认为这是在为他们组织特别的时刻。因为阿尔茨海默症患者有短期记忆丧失的问题。所以这些特别的时刻有时就是他们所拥有的一切。
This is Judy Dejong who organized the fake wedding. It is her fourth one for Alzheimers patients.
这是组织这场假婚礼的朱迪·德容。这是她为阿尔茨海默症患者举办的第四场婚礼了。
Could you do this wedding again next week and most of them wouldn't remember that it had happened this week?
你下周再举办一次这样的婚礼，他们中大多数人会不记得这周发生过吗？
We could do it tonight even and they wouldn't-- may not have remembered that. Absolutely. So we have planned a special moment, a moment in time for them.
我们甚至今晚就能再办一场，他们可能根本记不住。绝对会这样。所以我们为他们策划了一个特别的时刻，一个属于他们的时间片段。
It must be so odd for you to work creating moments for them that are instantly gone.
为你来说，创造这些转瞬即逝的时刻一定很奇怪吧。
Well, so many people say, why do you go to all that trouble when you know they're not going to remember? And I just think, as a caregiver, that is our role for them is to provide these special moments.
嗯，很多人问，既然知道他们记不住，为什么还要费这么大劲？我只是认为，作为护理员，我们的职责就是为他们提供这些特别的时刻。
Today on our program, giving the people what they want, we bring you five stories of people who went to extraordinary lengths to give people what they wanted. It's interesting what people want and what they would do for those who will give it to them. Act One, Let Them Eat Cake, Wedding Cake. You've probably already gotten a sense of what that act is going to be about. Act Two, God Shed His Grace on Thee. In that act, the astonishing story of how an entire country-- a big country, a country that you have heard of-- got named after somebody who was a fraud, but the kind of fraud that people love, the kind of fraud who knows how to please a crowd.
今天我们的节目主题是“满足人们的需求”，我们将带给您五个关于人们为了满足他人需求而不惜付出非凡努力的故事。人们想要什么以及他们会为了得到它而做什么，这很有趣。第一幕，《让他们吃蛋糕，结婚蛋糕》。你可能已经猜到这一幕的内容了。第二幕，《上帝将恩典洒向你》。在这一幕里，讲述了一个令人震惊的故事：整个国家——一个大国，一个你听说过的国家——是如何以一个骗子的名字命名的，但那是人们喜爱的那种骗子，那种懂得如何取悦大众的骗子。
Act Three, Have Paint Will Travel, a man who does murals for hire on the living room walls inside Chicago public housing units reveals what it is that people want on their walls now that black and gold panthers are sort of played out. Act Four, Handing People Their Dreams, a clerk at a humble midwestern video shop tells all about handing people adult videos for a living. Act Five, What Daddy Wants. In that act, a family tries to give Daddy what he wants, even if he does not seem to want it sometimes. Stay with us.
第三幕，《有颜料，就能旅行》，一位受雇在芝加哥公共住房公寓墙壁上绘制壁画的男子揭示了人们现在想要什么样的墙面装饰，因为黑豹和金豹的图案已经过时了。第四幕，《递给人们梦想》，一家平庸的中西部录像带店的店员讲述了她以递送成人录像带为生的经历。第五幕，《爸爸想要什么》。在这一幕里，一家人试图给爸爸他们想要的东西，即使他有时看起来并不想要。请继续收听。
Act One, Let Them Eat Wedding Cake. It turns out, the hardest part of staging a fake wedding at the Country House Residence in Davenport was finding a groom. The bride's real life boyfriend did not own a suit. And they're kind of on-again, off-again anyway. So he was out. He spent the day fishing. Somebody suggested the bride's brother play the groom but even the thought of that gave the bride the willies. I'm not kissing him, she told her mother.
第一幕，《让他们吃结婚蛋糕》。事实证明，在达文波特的乡间别墅公寓策划一场假婚礼，最困难的部分是找到新郎。新娘现实生活中的男朋友没有西装。而且他们的关系本来就分分合合的。所以他出局了。他那天去钓鱼了。有人建议让新娘的弟弟扮演新郎，但连想一想都让新娘感到毛骨悚然。她告诉她妈妈：“我才不要亲他。”
For a while it looked like one of the certified nurse's assistant, Jason Allender would step in. But as fate would have it, he had another wedding-- a real one-- in which he would also be the groom, planned for the week after the fake wedding. And his real fiance had a few thoughts about him going through the motions in a separate ceremony with a cute high school girl.
有一段时间，看起来会由认证护理助理杰森·阿伦德顶替。但命运弄人，他下周刚好有一场婚礼——一场真的婚礼——他也是新郎。而他真正的未婚妻对于他在一周前与一个可爱的女高中生进行另一场仪式有着一些想法。
She didn't like it. She did not like it at all.
她不喜欢。她一点也不喜欢。
What did she say?
她说了什么？
No. No.
不。不行。
I understand. It kind of takes the shine off the other wedding if you're doing a wedding the week before.
我理解。如果你在一周前刚办过一场婚礼，这确实会让你另一场婚礼的光彩减弱。
Yeah, a little bit. And she said, they want you to kiss her? And I was like well, yeah, probably on the cheek. And she said, no you're not.
是的，有点。她说，“他们想让你亲她？”我说，“嗯，是啊，可能是在脸颊上。”她说，“不，你不能。”
The groom they got, Ashley, had done a lot of high school plays and was charmingly unflappable. The kiss, he told me, was just another stage kiss.
他们找来的新郎阿什利，演过很多高中戏剧，而且表现得非常从容淡定。他告诉我，那个吻只是舞台上的吻而已。
That's what got me, that good-looking guy.
就是那个帅小伙吸引了我。
The women at the Residence got into the wedding more than the men, as happens even when people are not Alzheimer's patients. I talk with them about the bride's dress, the cake, the presents. These conversations wove in and out of coherence. When I sat down with these two women, they were passing back and forth a pair of eyeglasses, each of them unable to remember if it was hers.
疗养院的女性比男性更投入这场婚礼，即使在非阿尔茨海默症患者中也是如此。我和她们谈论新娘的礼服、蛋糕和礼物。这些对话在连贯与不连贯之间徘徊。当我坐下来和这两位女士交谈时，她们正在来回传递一副眼镜，两人都记不清那是谁的了。
This is my glasses. But they don't fit right on my ears, see? It's a whole different pair of glasses. Do you have another pair of glasses that you--
这是我的眼镜。但它们戴在耳朵上不太合适，你看？这是完全不同的另一副。你还有另一副眼镜吗——
No, these are mine.
不，这是我的。
--Those are yours. Well, I don't know.
——那是你的。好吧，我不知道。
Are those hers?
那是她的吗？
No, I thought that I was getting--
不，我以为我拿到的是——
Are they broken already?
它们已经坏了吗？
I don't-- I hope not. No, they're not broken.
我不知道——我希望没有。不，它们没坏。
So, what did you think of the wedding?
那么，你觉得这场婚礼怎么样？
Well, it's all right now. But for a while I didn't like it too good at all.
嗯，现在还好。但有一段时间我一点也不喜欢。
Why is that?
为什么呢？
It was cold and slippery.
当时又冷又滑。
This is some old memory, not our wedding. This happened a lot.
这是一些旧的记忆，不是我们的婚礼。这种情况经常发生。
It was a real nice wedding. It really was. I love her dress.
那是一场非常好的婚礼。真的很好。我喜欢她的裙子。
I think they're pretty great kids. I don't know them real well. I don't know if she just has one little girl or what, but they stopped up at our house one night, the father and her, and man is she smart. She was really smart. But every so often her mother had to go, psst, [SNIFF SNIFF] on the seat of her pants.
我觉得这些孩子很棒。我不太了解他们。我不知道她是否只有一个小女孩还是别的什么，但有一天晚上，她父亲和她路过我们家，天哪，她真聪明。她真的很聪明。但每隔一段时间，她妈妈就得“嘘，[吸鼻子声]”拍拍她的屁股。
If I had to guess, I would say that the one person who is going to remember this day is the bride, 18-year-old Lisa Arret. She was working her regular shift at Country House when Judy Dejong invited her to play the part.
如果让我猜的话，我会说唯一会记住这一天的人是新娘，18岁的丽莎·阿雷特。当时她正在乡间别墅正常值班，朱迪·德容邀请她扮演这个角色。
It was actually-- I was screaming, I was so excited. I was like, yes, yes. Because in school and stuff like that, I've never been really the center of attention when it comes to-- or being even the main character in a play. And it was just like wow, this is it, this is it and stuff like that. And I, of course, didn't realize how big it would be. Actually, when I had the dress on and I was standing-- after I put it on I was waiting for them to say, you can come out now-- and I was standing in front of the mirror with the veil and everything. And then I sat on the bed, and I see the veil next to me. It's just like, oh my god, I'm in my wedding dress. It's just like, I don't know if I'll ever be in a wedding dress again.
其实当时我兴奋得尖叫起来。我说，好啊，好啊。因为在学校之类的地方，我从来没当过焦点，甚至没当过戏剧的主角。当时的感觉就像是“哇，就是这个，就是这个”之类的。我当然没意识到这会有多盛大。其实，当我穿上礼服站在那里——穿好之后，我等着他们说可以出去了——我站在镜子前，戴着面纱和一切。然后我坐在床上，看着旁边的面纱。心里想的是，天哪，我穿着婚纱。那种感觉就像，我不知道以后还有没有机会再穿上婚纱。
There was one resident that-- she kept looking at me in the dress. She kept looking over at me. And she kept looking like she was going to stand up and come over to me so I went over to her. And she had tears in her eyes. And she was like, you look so beautiful. I'm like, thank you so much. And I'm like, you look beautiful too. And times like those, I kind of know that when I change back into my clothes and you go back up to them, they're not going to know it was you in the wedding dress. They're not going to recognize me or not know who I am anymore, but it's still living in the moment, it's still appreciating the moment.
有一位住户——她一直盯着我穿婚纱的样子看。她不停地看向我。看起来好像要站起来向我走过来，所以我走了过去。她眼里含着泪水。她说：“你看起来真美。”我说：“太谢谢你了。”我又说：“你看起来也很美。”在那样的时刻，我知道当我换回衣服回到她们身边时，她们不会知道那个穿婚纱的人是我。她们不会认出我，也不会再知道我是谁了，但活在当下，依然在欣赏那一刻。
To Lisa, the whole experience was one of those things that you don't even know you want until somebody gives it to you, which in a way is what the wedding was for the residents too.
对丽莎来说，整个经历是那种在别人给你之前你甚至不知道自己想要的东西，从某种意义上说，这场婚礼对住户们来说也是这样。
[MUSIC- "TIME ENOUGH FOR ROCKING WHEN WE'RE OLD" BY THE MAGNETIC FIELDS]
[音乐- 《当我们老了，有足够的时间摇滚》，磁场乐队作品]
Act Two, God Shed His Grace on Thee. In our radio story, 500 years in the making, a fable of giving people what they want in a global scale, the story of-- stay with me here-- how America actually got his name, from Mr. Jack Hitt.
第二幕，《上帝将恩典洒向你》。在我们的广播故事里，这是一个历时500年的故事，一个在全球范围内满足人们需求的寓言，讲述了——请跟着我的思路——美国究竟是如何得名的，由杰克·希特讲述。
I got clocked in the head the first time I ever delved into the mystery of how America got its name. It was third grade, Porter-Gaud, South Carolina. Mrs. Poulnot had just explained that Amerigo Vespucci was a noted explorer. And from the back of the class I observed, "What'd he do that was so great?" After all, who wasn't a noted explorer back then? Mrs. Poulnot had this little trick, turning her enormous wedding ring around on her finger and thumping you in the head. When the pain receded, I stepped into the library on my own. By then I was 30 and lived in New York City.
我第一次探究美国得名之谜时，脑袋被敲了一下。那是三年级，在南卡罗来纳州的波特-高德学校。波诺太太刚刚解释说亚美利哥·韦斯普奇是一位著名的探险家。我在教室后排观察道：“他做了什么了不起的事吗？”毕竟，当时谁不是位著名的探险家呢？波诺太太有个小把戏，她会转动手指上巨大的结婚戒指，然后敲你的头。当疼痛消退后，我独自走进了图书馆。那时我已经30岁，住在纽约市。
Think about it. A third of planet Earth is named for Amerigo Vespucci. But why? Why aren't we named for the European who first landed here? The United States of Colombia. Try it out. God bless Columbia. Death to Colombia. This Colombian Life . It works.
想想看。地球三分之一的土地以亚美利哥·韦斯普奇命名。但为什么呢？为什么我们不是以第一位到达这里的欧洲人的名字命名的？“哥伦比亚合众国”。试试看。上帝保佑哥伦比亚。打倒哥伦比亚。这部《哥伦比亚人生》。行得通。
I finally did figure it out. And it comes down to this-- it had nothing to do with exploration but everything to do with salesmanship. Columbus returned to tell us about the New World the way it really was. Vespucci described a different New World altogether, not the one he saw from the railing of his ship but the one he knew the folks back home wanted to believe in, the imaginary world they were certain had to exist somewhere. It's a tabloid rendition of the New World starring the usual cast-- hot naked girls, cannibals, dragons, pygmies and an island of giant women.
我终于弄明白了。归根结底——这与探索无关，完全是销售手段。哥伦布回来后告诉我们新大陆的真实情况。而韦斯普奇描述了一个完全不同的新大陆，不是他在船栏边看到的那个，而是他知道家乡的人们想要相信的那个，那个他们确信在某处一定存在着的想象世界。这是一个以通常阵容为主角的新大陆小报版本——火辣的裸女、食人族、龙、俾格米人以及一个巨女岛。
So, what happened? You ask. First off, get the old Amerigo out of your mind-- the noble map-maker pondering the stars with his astrolabe-- now replace him with a ne'er-do-well rich kid who flunked out of school and whose father landed him a job with another rich guy.
那么，发生了什么？你问。首先，把老亚美利哥从你的脑海里赶出去——那个用星盘思考星星的高贵地图制作者——现在把他替换成一个学业不及格、被父亲塞进另一个富人手下工作的无能富二代。
Amerigo was born into a family of great prominence in 15th century Florence. Remember Botticelli's painting, The Birth of Venus? The blond on the clamshell, that's Amerigo's cousin, Simonetta. Still, he couldn't master his Latin study so his father got him a position with one of the richest and most powerful people on the earth, Lorenzo de Medici. According to one Spanish historian, a Vespucci enthusiast, Amerigo, quote, "Was in charge of everything, dinner services, silver, the chests of damask, hangings, tapestries--" what we might call an entry level position.
亚美利哥出生于15世纪佛罗伦萨的一个显赫家族。还记得波提切利的画作《维纳斯的诞生》吗？贝壳上的那个金发女郎就是亚美利哥的堂妹西蒙内塔。尽管如此，他还是没能掌握拉丁文，所以他父亲让他进入了地球上最富有、最有权势的人之一洛伦佐·德·美第奇手下任职。据一位西班牙历史学家、韦斯普奇的狂热追随者说，亚美利哥当时“负责一切，餐具服务、银器、大马士革锦缎箱子、挂毯、壁毯——”我们可以称之为入门级职位。
Eventually, Lorenzo trusted Amerigo enough to send him as a scout to Spain. There were lots of business opportunities there at the time, mainly because Queen Isabella decided to unify the country by throwing out all the Jews and Arabs in that very busy year, 1492.
最终，洛伦佐足够信任亚美利哥，派他作为侦察兵去西班牙。当时那里有很多商业机会，主要是因为伊莎贝拉女王在那个非常繁忙的1492年，通过驱逐所有犹太人和阿拉伯人来统一了国家。
No one really knows what Amerigo did during this time. But as one writer put it, he "resolved to abandon trade and to aspire to something more praiseworthy and enduring." So he learned astronomy and managed to sail as navigator and map-maker on at least two voyages bound for the New World-- one from Spain and one from Portugal.
没人真正知道亚美利哥在这段时间做了什么。但正如一位作家所言，他“决定放弃贸易，去追求一些更值得称赞和持久的东西。”所以他学习了天文学，并设法作为领航员和地图制作者参加了至少两次前往新大陆的航行——一次来自西班牙，一次来自葡萄牙。
We still read Amerigo's writings every time we look at a map. In one harbor, Amerigo noticed that the natives elevated their huts on pilings above the water. Amerigo was reminded of Venice and wrote "Little Venice," or in Spanish, "Venezuela." While traveling from Portugal, Amerigo entered a huge river during January, plumbing the shallows of his imagination he wrote in Portuguese, "Rio de Janeiro."
每次我们看地图时，依然在读亚美利哥的著作。在一个港口，亚美利哥注意到当地人把房子建在水上的木桩上。亚美利哥想到了威尼斯，写下了“小威尼斯”，在西班牙语中就是“委内瑞拉”。在从葡萄牙旅行时，亚美利哥于一月进入了一条巨大的河流，他发挥想象力，用葡萄牙语写下了“里约热内卢”。
At this point in the story, the standard explanation in the grade school textbooks starts to crumble. We all learned that Amerigo's maps launched his fame. But that's not true. It's what accompanied them. Amerigo wrote several long letters home, one to his employer, Lorenzo de Medici. And without them this glorified steward would have disappeared into the vapors of history. So why didn't Mrs. Poulnot mention these letters? You only have to read them. Amerigo's letters are laced with crazy adventures and lewd encounters that are outrageous even by our jaded standards.
故事讲到这里，小学教科书里的标准解释开始崩溃了。我们都学过是亚美利哥的地图让他声名大噪。但那不是真的。是伴随地图的东西。亚美利哥写了几封长信回家，一封是给他的雇主洛伦佐·德·美第奇的。如果没有这些信，这位光荣的管家就会消失在历史的烟雾中。那么为什么波诺太太没提这些信呢？你只需要读读它们。亚美利哥的信里充斥着疯狂的冒险和淫秽的邂逅，即使以我们现在麻木的标准来看也令人咋舌。
If your children can understand the prim syntax of the Victorian era, you might want to send them out of the room for a minute. Here's one description of the free-spirited savages of the New World.
如果你的孩子能理解维多利亚时代那种古板的语法，你可能想让他们暂时离开房间一会。这是一段对新大陆自由奔放的野蛮人的描述。
Quote, "they do not practice marriage. Each man takes all the women he desires. And when he wishes to discard them, he repudiates them without discrediting himself or disgracing the woman. They are excessively libidinous, and the women much more than the men. For I refrain, out of decency, from telling of the art with which they gratify their immoderate lust."
原文是，“他们不实行婚姻。每个男人想占有谁就占有谁。当他想抛弃她们时，他就抛弃她们，不会给自己带来耻辱，也不会让女人蒙羞。他们极其淫荡，女性比男性更甚。因为出于礼貌，我在此不谈他们满足淫欲的技巧。”
Now imagine you are your average Venetian doge in 1505, eager to learn of the New World and you read this, "It was, to us, a matter of astonishment that none was to be seen among them who had a flabby breast. And those who had borne children were not to be distinguished from virgins by the shape and shrinking of the womb. And in the other parts of the body, similar things were seen of which, in the interest of modesty, I make no mention." No mention, except in the very next sentence. "When they had the opportunity of copulating with Christians, urged by excessive lust, they defiled and prostituted themselves."
现在想象一下，你是1505年的一位普通威尼斯总督，渴望了解新大陆，你读到了这一段：“对我们来说，令人惊奇的是，在他们中间竟然看不到一个乳房松弛的人。那些生过孩子的女人从子宫的形状和萎缩程度上无法与处女区分开来。在身体的其他部位，也看到了类似的情况，出于谦虚，我不予提及。”不予提及，除了在紧接着的下一句。“当他们有机会与基督徒发生性关系时，在极度淫欲的驱使下，她们会玷污和出卖自己。”
Amerigo wields this time honored literary device constantly, resisting, trying to resist, and then yielding, baby, to more and more descriptions of a paradise of eternally youthful women with timeless breasts and nothing but eyes for a big, strong caballero. These essential themes may ring vaguely familiar because they are, in fact, the very same ones used today to sell Penthouse magazine.
亚美利哥不断地使用这种历史悠久的文学手法，表现出抵制，试图抵制，然后屈服，宝贝，描述着一个充满了永恒青春的女性、拥有完美乳房、眼里只有高大强壮绅士的乐园。这些基本主题听起来可能有些耳熟，因为事实上，它们正是今天用来推销《阁楼》杂志的主题。
Dear Penthouse forum, I never thought it would happen to me. But one day, some explorer buddies and I were hugging the coast of the New World in our caravel when some comely natives signalled to come on board.
亲爱的《阁楼》论坛，我从没想过这种事会发生在我身上。有一天，我和几个探险家伙伴乘着卡拉维尔帆船沿着新大陆海岸航行时，一些美貌的土著示意我们上船。
Me, I don't even believe that Amerigo Vespucci wrote the letters. The originals disappeared long ago. What we have are copies published on a newfangled machine called a printing press. Amerigo's originals, by whatever path, found their way to the new media of the day. These Ur journalists lived during the infancy of this new technology and printing was reshaping the Old World as rapidly as the computer has transformed our own. When Columbus set sail, for instance, there were 268 registered printers working and competing in Venice alone, even though Johann Gutenberg's Bible was not yet 50 years old.
我本人甚至不相信亚美利哥·韦斯普奇写过这些信。原作早已消失。我们所拥有的是在一种叫做印刷机的新奇机器上出版的副本。亚美利哥的原作通过各种途径，找到了当时的新媒体。这些原始记者生活在这一新技术发展的初期，印刷术重塑旧世界的速度就像计算机改变我们的世界一样迅速。例如，当哥伦布起航时，仅威尼斯就有268家注册印刷商在工作和竞争，尽管约翰·古腾堡的圣经问世还不到50年。
At this time there was no First Amendment, no copyright law, and no tradition of authorship. These entrepreneurial printers, I believe, simply re-wrote Amerigo's flat prose and exaggerated his plodding descriptions of the New World, knowing it would sell better. The sloppy hand of the hack journalist is evident everywhere. One transatlantic route Amerigo describes would have plowed him straight across the continent and landed him in Seattle, Washington.
当时没有第一修正案，没有版权法，也没有作者传统。我相信，这些投机取巧的印刷商只是改写了亚美利哥平淡的散文，夸大了他那乏味的对新大陆的描述，因为他们知道这样更好卖。二流记者的草率手法随处可见。亚美利哥描述的一条跨大西洋路线，若是真的，他会直接横穿整个大陆，降落在华盛顿州的西雅图。
But what really gives away the scriveners who edited Amerigo is just how well they knew their audience. The prevailing mythology of 1500 held that beyond the setting sun existed a strange and turbulent world, inhabited not just by exotic beauties, but also by every kind of oddity imaginable. So Amerigo visits an island of giant women, cracks open a huge oyster to find a 130 pearls, and meets the iron man cannibal of all time, a guy who claims to have eaten 300 people.
但真正暴露这些编辑亚美利哥文字的抄写员的，是他们对自己读者的了解程度。1500年盛行的神话认为，在落日之外存在着一个陌生而动荡的世界，不仅居住着异国美女，还有各种各样的奇观。于是亚美利哥访问了一个巨女岛，撬开了一个大牡蛎发现了130颗珍珠，并遇到了史上最强大的铁人食人族，一个声称吃了300人的家伙。
There are many violent adventures and more sexual encounters, including one tribe that possessed a most unusual sex potion, which, in the interest of modesty, I will make no mention. See how nicely that works?
还有许多暴力冒险和更多的性邂逅，包括一个部落拥有一种最不寻常的性药水，出于礼貌，我不予提及。看，这招多管用？
Then you read Columbus' letters, which were not rewritten. They are long on descriptions of big leaves and friendly natives. A typical racy passage reads, "There are on the island seven or eight kinds of palm trees, which far excel ours in height and beauty. There are also excellent pine trees, vast plains and meadows. The convenience of the harbors in this island and the remarkable number of rivers contributing to the healthfulness of man exceed belief."
然后你读读哥伦布的信，那些没被改写的信。里面大多是对大叶子和友好土著的描述。一段典型的香艳段落写道：“岛上有七八种棕榈树，在高度和美感上远远胜过我们的。还有极好的松树，广阔的平原和草地。岛上港口的便利和非凡的河流数量对人类健康的贡献超乎想象。”
Needless to say, that kind of prose didn't quite have the same box office that Amerigo's letters did. One academic study of all the explorer's best-selling publications has Columbus' letters in second place with 22 editions. Amerigo? 60 editions, including a blockbuster in Czech. Strange, none was published in Spain where Amerigo lived.
不用说，那种文字的票房号召力比不上亚美利哥的信。一项关于所有探险家畅销出版物的学术研究显示，哥伦布的信件以22个版本位居第二。亚美利哥？60个版本，包括捷克语的畅销书。奇怪的是，没有一本书是在亚美利哥居住的西班牙出版的。
As Amerigo's letters move swiftly across Europe, one copy found its way into the hands of a small group of academics living in France in 1507. They were working on publishing a grand edition of the most respected geography text of the day, Ptolemy's Cosmographia. In this edition is a large map drawn by a cartographer named Martin Waldseemuller. This man's name you should remember. This is the man who named America. Martin Waldseemuller. On this enormous map, stamped across a few continental chunks, it reads-- for the very first time-- America. Beneath it, in the deep blue sea, Waldseemuller added an explanation.
随着亚美利哥的信件迅速传遍欧洲，一份副本在1507年落入了一群生活在法国的学者手中。他们正在着手出版当时最受尊敬的地理文本——托勒密的《地理学指南》的宏大版本。在这个版本中，有一张由制图师马丁·瓦尔德塞米勒绘制的大地图。这个人的名字你该记住。就是他命名了美国。马丁·瓦尔德塞米勒。在这张巨大的地图上，横跨几块大陆，第一次印上了——美洲（America）。在它下方的深蓝大海中，瓦尔德塞米勒加上了解释。
"I see no reason why we should not call it America, that is to say, land of Amerigo, its discover, a man of sagacious wit."
“我看不出有什么理由我们不能称之为美洲，也就是亚美利哥的土地，它的发现者，一位富有智慧的人。”
Apparently, a poet friend intoxicated by Amerigo's prose had talked Waldseemuller into it. Later he changed his mind and never again included the name on any of his maps. But the name began to catch on. And 31 years later, when the great cartographer Gerard Mercator became the first person to write North and South America on a map, the issue was settled. America was a place.
显然，一位被亚美利哥的文字迷住的诗友说服了瓦尔德塞米勒。后来他改变了主意，再也没有在他的任何地图上包含这个名字。但这个名字开始流行起来。31年后，当伟大的制图师杰拉杜斯·麦卡托成为第一个在地图上写下“北美洲”和“南美洲”的人时，问题就解决了。美洲成了一个地方。
Nowadays, historians tell two stories, pro and con, about Amerigo. Some struggle to rewrite his thin resume to make it match up to his name. The others, they just scream. The Harvard historian Samuel Eliot Morison called Amerigo, quote, "A liar and the stupid boy of his class who flunked Greek and so had to go into business."
如今，历史学家对亚美利哥有两种说法，支持和反对。一些人努力改写他那薄弱的简历以使其与他的名字相符。另一些人则只剩下尖叫。哈佛历史学家塞缪尔·艾略特·莫里森称亚美利哥为“骗子，班里挂科的笨蛋，因为没学好希腊语，所以不得不经商。”
Ralph Waldo Emerson wrote, "Strange that broad America must wear the name of a thief. Amerigo Vespucci, the pickle dealer at Seville, who managed in this lying world to supplant Columbus and baptize half the earth with his own dishonest name."
拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生写道：“奇怪的是，广袤的美国必须背负一个贼的名字。亚美利哥·韦斯普奇，那个塞维利亚的腌菜商，竟然在这个谎言世界里取代了哥伦布，用自己不诚实的名字为半个地球洗礼。”
Amerigo died broke and without ever knowing that a third of the globe would bear his name. But I've come to think it's the perfect name. Columbus may have discovered the New World, but Vespucci sold it to us. How poetic is it that the future home of skywriting, ballyhoo, and P.R. would be named after someone so willing to give folks what they wanted? Hype and spin permeate our every institution, our politics, and our movies. The things we sell and the stock market that underwrites them. Vespucci's letters totally oversold the whole place with a bunch of preposterous lies that became a blockbuster best seller. He really had no idea what he was doing and never earned a doubloon himself from the whole thing. And then dying unawares, had the entire mess rewritten one more time, this time as a stately tale of a great navigator, high up in the crow's nest in every third grade textbook, peering nobly at the stars. The naming of America wasn't a mistake, it was prophecy.
亚美利哥死时身无分文，甚至不知道全球三分之一的地方会以他的名字命名。但我开始认为这是一个完美的名字。哥伦布可能发现了新大陆，但韦斯普奇把它卖给了我们。未来的“空中广告”、大肆宣传和公关的发源地，居然以一个如此乐于满足大众需求的人命名，这是多么富有诗意啊？炒作和包装渗透到我们的每一个机构、政治和电影中。我们销售的东西和支持它们的股票市场。韦斯普奇的信件用一大堆荒唐的谎言完全高估了那个地方，结果成了一本畅销书。他完全不知道自己在做什么，自己也没从整件事中赚到一个金币。然后在不知不觉中死去，整个混乱被再次改写，这次成了一个伟大航海家的庄严故事，在每本小学教科书里高高在上地坐在瞭望塔里，高贵地凝视着星星。美国的命名不是一个错误，而是一个预言。
Jack Hitt lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特住在纽黑文。
[MUSIC- "IN AMERICA" BY FASTBACKS]
[音乐- 《在美国》，Fastbacks乐队作品]
Act Three, Have Paint, Will Travel. Well, now we move from giving people what they want on a continental scale to giving them what they want on the most local level possible, namely in their own living rooms. Milton Reid paints murals for his livelihood inside people's apartments in the public housing projects here in Chicago, specifically in the Robert Taylor Homes, which are high-rise buildings on the city's south side. A neighborhood, by the way, where the city has recently been tearing down public housing buildings. Around the neighborhood, Reid is known simply as the artist, as in, hey artist, how much do you charge for a mural? Reid charges between $50 and $200.
第三幕，《有颜料，就能旅行》。好吧，现在我们从全球范围内满足人们的需求，转移到最本地化的层面，即他们自己的客厅。弥尔顿·里德以在芝加哥公共住房项目的公寓内绘制壁画为生，具体是在罗伯特·泰勒之家，那是位于城市南区的高层建筑。顺便说一句，在这个社区，市政府最近一直在拆除公共住房建筑。在社区里，里德被简称为“艺术家”，比如，“嘿，艺术家，你画一张壁画收费多少？”里德收费在50美元到200美元之间。
When he started painting apartment walls, the thing that most people requested were panthers, often in black and gold to match their furniture. But soon, Reid got other requests.
当他刚开始画公寓墙壁时，人们最常要求的是黑豹，通常是黑金相间的，以搭配他们的家具。但很快，里德收到了其他要求。
And I said, "Uh oh. Another good idea."
我说，“哦，另一个好主意。”
She said, "I don't want no panthers," she told me, "I want just a sky here with water and trees."
她说，“我不要黑豹，”她告诉我，“我只想在这儿画一片蓝天，有水和树。”
I said, "Okay, you want something like a landscape, right? Something like that."
我说，“好吧，你想要风景画之类的，对吧？类似于那种。”
"And I want the sun coming off the water, all the shininess."
“我想要阳光照在水面上，那种亮晶晶的感觉。”
I said, "I understand, I know exactly what you're talking about. Let me try to make you feel good. So all my customers started doing it.
我说，“我明白了，我完全知道你在说什么。让我试着让你心情好起来。所以我的所有顾客都开始这样做。”
Most of the people take pictures of them and their girlfriends standing by the landscape like they're out there. They say, "Oh, it looks so real. Look at the--" I come to their house, they show me a photograph. They say "Don't let nobody else see." I look at it. I say, oh no. Here she is, her and her man standing up naked by the landscape. Or you'll see the man lying down like they're at the lake or something.
大多数人会拍下他们和女朋友站在风景画旁边的照片，好像他们真的在那里一样。他们说，“哦，看起来太真实了。你看——”我去他们家，他们给我看照片。他们说，“别让别人看到。”我看了看。我说，哦不。照片里她和她的男人在风景画旁赤身裸体。或者你会看到那个男人躺着，就像在湖边或者什么地方。
They say, "It looks so real, doesn't it?"
他们说，“看起来太真实了，不是吗？”
I say, "Yeah." OK, front room.
我说，“是啊。”好吧，前厅。
You either want a panther or you want a landscape. In a kid's room it was always a cartoon. In a bathroom, it was always dolphin, fish, or ducks. It couldn't be anything else. I hate to tell you, but some people have some weird imaginations. I'm sitting up here doing some work and this girl had me draw this guy standing by a tree taking a leak, right? Now OK, I did this, right? But the oddest thing happened with this girl. She called me back down the next day. "I want you to draw Jesus Christ on that wall right there. I want that in color. And I'm giving you $50."
你不是想要黑豹就是想要风景画。在孩子房间里总是卡通人物。在浴室里，总是海豚、鱼或鸭子。不可能是别的。我不想告诉你，但有些人的想象力确实很古怪。我在这儿干活，那个女孩让我画一个男的站在树边撒尿，对吧？现在好了，我画了，对吧？但这个女孩身上发生了最奇怪的事。第二天她又叫我回来。“我要你在那面墙上画耶稣基督。我要彩色的。我给你50美元。”
I said, "Yeah, but can't you understand? You've got a guy right here peeing on a wall and you got Jesus right here."
我说，“是啊，但你明白吗？你这儿墙上画着个撒尿的人，那边却画着耶稣。”
She said, "I'm paying you $50. You going to do it or not?" Let me do what the customer says. So I do it, right?
她说，“我付你50美元。你到底画不画？”让我按顾客说的做吧。所以我画了，对吧？
Then I have people come out with, "Ohh, I saw that Jesus Christ you drew on her-- can you draw Jesus for me?" So I start putting Jesus on people's wall. Then they'll say, "Why did you draw my Jesus that dark? I want my Jesus white." Most people want-- most of them wanted Jesus white, right?
然后有些人跑来说，“哦，我看到了你给她画的耶稣——你能为我画个耶稣吗？”所以我就开始在人们墙上画耶稣。然后他们说，“你为什么把我画的耶稣画得那么黑？我要白色的耶稣。”大多数人想要——他们大多数人想要白色的耶稣，对吧？
And I said, "Well really, Jesus really wasn't white. He was a--"
我说，“嗯，其实，耶稣本来就不是白人。他是——”
"Look, I'm paying you. You do it the way I say to do it. I know how he looked."
“听着，我付你钱。你就按我说的画。我知道他长什么样。”
I said, "OK, I guess you're right." Because see, they probably met Jesus in person, so.
我说，“OK，我想你是对的。”因为你看，他们可能亲眼见过耶稣，所以。
I had a guy mention something like-- he told me it really hurt me when I found out. And he said, "Remember you drew me and my wife on the wall?"
有个家伙提到了一些事——他告诉我的事在我发现后真的很伤我的心。他说，“还记得你把我和我妻子画在墙上吗？”
I said, "Yeah, I remember that."
我说，“记得，我记得。”
He said, "I want you to draw it again in the other room, me and her and a kid, because we've got a kid now."
他说，“我想请你在另一个房间再画一次，我和她，还有一个孩子，因为我们现在有孩子了。”
OK, I've got to drawing it, right? I didn't know until I finished. He told me, "My wife passed. She died." A lot of people started having me do that, of their people that died. You know, around the Robert Taylor there were so many deaths, where young people just shooting each other, killing each other.
OK，我开始画了，对吧？直到画完我才知道。他告诉我，“我妻子去世了。她死了。”很多人开始让我这样做，画他们死去的亲人。你知道，在罗伯特·泰勒之家周围发生了太多的死亡，年轻人就在那互相枪击，杀害对方。
The oddest request I ever had in my life-- here goes. We're in the Robert Taylor standing up and we're on about the 10th floor. She said, "I want you to paint my whole wall like there's no wall here at all, like you can look right outside.
我这辈子收到过最奇怪的请求——就是这个。我们在罗伯特·泰勒之家，大概在10楼。她说，“我要你把整面墙画得好像那里根本没有墙一样，好像你可以直接看到外面。”
I say, "OK, I understand what you're saying. You want me to draw where it's like a whole wall's been busted out right here, so you can walk in your house-- when you open her door and look in her house it'll be just like you're looking right outside. You'll see the clouds, you'll see the highrises downtown. OK, now, that's not what really makes it odd. It's what she had me do when I came back the next week. And this is what she had me do.
我说，“OK，我明白你的意思了。你是要我画得像墙壁破开了一个大洞，所以当你走进她的房子——当你打开门往里看时，感觉就像真的在往外看。你会看到云，你会看到市中心的高楼。OK，这还不是最奇怪的地方。最奇怪的是她下周回来时让我做的事。这就是她让我做的。”
"Now, I want you to draw me standing right here on the side. Just draw me, you're going to draw the back of my head, something like this. You're going to draw this part of me doing this." Her right hand is going forward and her right feet, everything is forward, right? It's just like a wrecking crew came along and just tore that part out and she has her arms sticking out there like that outside the window. And I couldn't understand her. Why would you want me to draw you doing like this? Maybe she's dancing. Or maybe she wants me to draw her, making it like she's pushing her hand out there so she can feel the air out there. So I did it and I charged her. And guess what she wanted? She didn't tell me until I finished painting her.
“现在，我要你把我画在这一侧。就画我，画我的后脑勺，像这样。画我身体的这一部分做这个动作。”她的右手向前伸，右脚也是，一切都朝前，对吧？就像有个拆迁队过来把那部分拆了，她双臂像那样伸出窗外。我不理解她。你为什么想让我画你做这个动作？也许她在跳舞。或者也许她想让我画她，表现得好像她在把手伸出去，这样她就能感受到外面的空气。所以我画了，也收了钱。你猜她想要什么？直到我画完她才告诉我。
She said, "OK, down here, I want you to draw my man. So it should appear that he's further away from me. So you make him small."
她说，“OK，在这下面，我要你画我的男人。所以看起来他应该离我远一点。所以你要把他画小。”
I said, "I know how to draw. I know about perspective. His feet were sticking up to the sky. And his hands were going down. You could see his mouth open real wide and in perspective, a foreshortening, you'll see one of his feet coming this way in a big shoe. Because he has one leg going way back and the other leg going further, closer to you. That lady-- I actually drew this lady pushing this man out the window.
我说，“我知道怎么画。我懂透视。他的脚指向天空。手朝下。你能看到他的嘴张得很大，在透视效果下，也就是前缩法，你会看到他的一只脚向这边伸出来，穿着大鞋子。因为他的一条腿向后伸，另一条腿伸得更远，离你更近。那位女士——我实际上画的是这个女人把这个男人推向窗外。”
Once they tear all the Robert Taylors down, which they're going to eventually do, it won't decrease my business. It will only increase. I know that. I'm working. I'm doing more work now than I've ever done in homes. Most of them are getting are Section Eight, and I'm going to other new row houses in Milwaukee and Calumet. They have me paint exactly the same thing they had in their house before. They say, "I want the same thing from where you had my house looking. I want it just like that."
一旦他们把所有的罗伯特·泰勒之家都拆了，他们最终会拆的，这不会减少我的业务。只会增加。我知道这一点。我在干活。我现在在家做的活比以往任何时候都多。他们大多数人领的是第八节补贴，我去了密尔沃基和卡卢梅特其他新的排屋。他们让我画和他们以前家里一模一样的画。他们说，“我要和你以前画在我家的一样。我要它像那样。”
The real trend that's really going on now-- since they are tearing down the Robert Taylors-- they want me to come to their home and paint the Robert Taylor Homes in their front room. When you first walk in that door-- when you first open the door up, the first thing you'll see is the projects. And you say, "Ah, they've been torn down a long time ago." And the first that comes to your mind, "You used to live in a Robert Taylor." And they want everybody to know this.
现在真正流行的趋势是——因为他们正在拆除罗伯特·泰勒之家——他们要我到他们家去，把罗伯特·泰勒之家画在他们的前厅。当你第一次走进那扇门——当你第一次打开门，你看到的第一件事就是那些公寓楼。你会说，“啊，它们早就拆了。”而你脑海里浮现的第一反应是，“你以前住在罗伯特·泰勒之家。”他们想让所有人都知道这一点。
Milton Reid, he spoke with reporter Alex Kotlowitz whose most recent book is The Other Side of the River . His story was produced by Amy Dorn. Coming up, porn. You heard me. Porn. That's in a minute from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
弥尔顿·里德与记者亚历克斯·科特洛维茨进行了交流，他的最新著作是《河流的另一边》。这个故事由艾米·多恩制作。接下来的节目，色情内容。你没听错。色情。国际公共广播电台和芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续，我们将在那一分钟后为您播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Give the People What They Want, stories of people whose thankless job is to do just that. We have arrived at Act Four of our show-- Act Four, Handing People Their Dreams.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“满足人们的需求”，讲述的是那些吃力不讨好的工作就是做这些事的人们的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第四幕——第四幕，《递给人们梦想》。
For over a year, Ali Davis has been working at a video store for $6.50 an hour, giving people their fantasies. What I mean by that, of course, is that there is a huge porn section downstairs and she helps people get their porn. She watches customers in the security cameras, she has this "Voice of God" microphone she can use to boom her voice down there when she needs to-- and she does sometimes. She has these true tales to tell.
一年多来，阿里·戴维斯一直在一家录像带店工作，每小时6.5美元，给人们提供他们的幻想。我所说的意思当然是，楼下有一个巨大的色情区，她帮助人们获取他们的色情片。她通过监控摄像机监视顾客，她有一个“上帝之声”麦克风，需要时可以在那儿广播她的声音——有时确实需要。她有一些真实的故事要讲。
A note to listeners, there is nothing explicit in these stories. No sex acts are mentioned at all. Nothing. But it is about porn.
给听众的一个提示，这些故事里没有任何露骨内容。完全没有提到性行为。什么都没有。但这确实是关于色情内容的。
We all abuse the hand sanitizer. I know that over-the-counter antibacterial products are bad. I know that they actually give rise to hideous, resistant strains of bacteria. But still, we all abuse the hand sanitizer. We just can't help it. I use it so much that I lose all finger traction and can't open our plastic bags. I've had days when I've used it so much that I can't even make fingerprints on the glass countertop. It freaks me out. But the thought of not using it is worse.
我们都滥用洗手液。我知道非处方抗菌产品不好。我知道它们实际上会导致可怕的、耐药的细菌菌株。但尽管如此，我们还是滥用洗手液。我们就是忍不住。我用得太多，以至于失去了手指所有的抓地力，连塑料袋都打不开。有些日子我用得太多，甚至在玻璃柜台上都留不下指纹。这让我很恐慌。但想到不用它，情况更糟。
Contamination is everywhere. I see people sneezing onto the tape cases. They cough wetly into their palms right before handing me change. But the worst thing is when the tapes come back slippery, or worse yet, sticky. Repeat offenders get a note on their file that says, "Lube Warning." The first time, we discreetly but firmly remind the customer that the tapes need to come back clean. The second time, we hand them the tape, a bottle of Windex, and a paper towel and tell them to clean off the tape in full view of whoever else is at the counter. Other than that, there's not much we can do except acknowledge the destruction of the polite fiction.
污染无处不在。我看到人们对着磁带盒打喷嚏。他们把手心弄湿了咳嗽，然后紧接着把钱递给我。但最糟糕的是磁带还回来时湿滑的，或者更糟糕，黏糊糊的。惯犯的档案上会贴一张条子，上面写着“润滑警告”。第一次，我们谨慎但坚定地提醒顾客磁带需要清理干净后还回来。第二次，我们把磁带、一瓶洗洁精喷雾和纸巾递给他们，让他们在柜台旁任何人的注视下清理磁带。除此之外，除了承认这种虚伪礼貌的破碎，我们无能为力。
The polite fiction is something nobody really believes but we all pretend to because it makes life so much easier. An anthropology professor once told me a story about a pygmy couple. Pygmy divorce involves, quite literally, breaking up the home. The couple tears apart their house and once it's down, the union is dissolved. One anthropologist was watching a long-married couple have a fight. It escalated until the wife threatened to leave, and the husband yelled something along the lines of "Fine." And so, there was nothing the wife could do but start tearing down the house. She began tearing off the leaves that made up the roof, clearly miserable. The husband looked wretched too. But at this point, neither could back down without losing face. And by now, the whole village was watching.
礼貌的虚构是没人真正相信，但我们都假装相信的东西，因为它让生活变得容易得多。一位人类学教授曾给我讲过一对俾格米夫妻的故事。俾格米人的离婚，字面意义上就是拆散家园。这对夫妇拆掉他们的房子，一旦拆完，婚姻就解散了。一位人类学家正在观察一对结婚多年的夫妻吵架。矛盾升级，妻子威胁要离开，丈夫吼了类似“随你便”的话。于是，妻子别无选择，只能开始拆房子。她开始撕掉组成屋顶的叶子，明显非常痛苦。丈夫看起来也很可怜。但在这一点上，谁也不能退缩，否则就会丢面子。此时，整个村庄都在看着。
Finally, the husband called out the Pygmy equivalent of, "You're right, honey, the roof is dirty. It'll look much better once we get those leaves washed." The two of them started carrying leaves down to the river, soon with the help of the whole village, and then washed and rebuilt the roof-- a whole village happily indulging each other.
最后，丈夫喊出了相当于俾格米语的：“你说得对，亲爱的，屋顶脏了。等我们把叶子洗干净，它会好看得多。”他们俩开始把叶子搬到河边，很快在全村人的帮助下，洗净并重建了屋顶——整个村庄快乐地互相迁就。
The polite fiction of our village, the porn section village, is that while people do generally use porn for the purpose of self-pleasuring, there is no reason to believe that this particular customer will be doing so. For all we know, he's taking them to a stag party, or watching them as a joke with his girlfriend, or using them for research on his master's thesis. When it becomes graphically, tangibly, clear that that's not the case, we all get uncomfortable.
我们村庄的礼貌虚构，那个色情片村庄的礼貌虚构是，虽然人们普遍使用色情片来满足自我愉悦，但没有理由相信这位特定的顾客会这样做。据我们所知，他可能要把它们带到单身派对上，或者和女朋友开玩笑地看着玩，或者利用它们做硕士论文的研究。当显而易见地、切切实实地清楚不是那么回事时，我们都感到不舒服。
The destruction of the polite fiction is what creeps me out about one of my weekend regulars. He comes in when I open at 9:00, then chooses and rents two movies. He leaves for exactly two movies worth of time, then comes back and returns them. I hate it because there's no way to pretend he's been doing anything else. Even a grad student has to stop the tape to take down notes occasionally.
礼貌虚构的破碎让我对一位周末常客感到毛骨悚然。他在我9点开门时进来，然后挑选并租两部电影。他离开正好两部电影的时间，然后回来还掉。我讨厌这样，因为没法假装他做了别的事。即使是研究生有时也得暂停录像带做笔记。
I'm convinced that porn is like alcohol. Some people can stop at just one every now and then. Some people binge on weekends. And some people are genuinely, horribly addicted. Most of my customers skew towards light porn rental. I see maybe half of them enough to sort of know who they are. And of those, maybe half again are heavy renters. A few tip into the danger zone-- six movies, every single day. Even with specials and frequent renter cards they end up spending thousands of dollars a year. On weekends, the store fills up almost immediately. The store opens at 9:00. I usually do about 20 minutes of set up and hit the front door at 9:00 on the dot by the store clock. There is always someone waiting to get to the porn.
我深信色情片就像酒精。有些人偶尔只看一部就能停下来。有些人周末狂看。还有些人是真正、可怕的成瘾者。我的大多数顾客偏向于轻量级色情片租赁。我看到的顾客里，大约有一半人我足够熟悉，能知道他们是谁。而在这些人里，大约有一半是重度租赁者。有几个人进入了危险区——每天租六部电影。即使有特价和常客卡，他们一年也要花掉几千美元。周末，店里几乎立刻就挤满了人。店9点开门。我通常做大约20分钟的准备工作，并在店钟9点准时去开门。总有人等着看色情片。
Twice I've had a problem to deal with and opened the door at, say, 9:02. In both cases, a guy was actually pounding on the door when I got to it, not the same guy either. Both guys almost flipped out when I took the time to slide the sign from "Closed," to "Open" before turning the lock. When I first started at the store, this scared the hell out of me. I assumed that anyone who needed porn before noon was automatically a pervert. That was until I got to know them. If you don't count the porn addiction, they're really not such bad guys.
我有两次遇到问题需要处理，并在比如9:02才打开门。在这两次中，当我走过去时，真的有个家伙在撞门，还不是同一个人。在我花时间把标志从“关门”滑到“开门”并转动锁之前，两个家伙都快疯了。刚开始在店里工作时，这把我吓坏了。我以为任何中午前需要色情片的人自动就是个变态。直到我开始了解他们。如果你不算色情成瘾，他们真的不是什么坏人。
Mr. Orange Hat is a registered nurse and leapt to my defense when another customer pitched a fit at me. Mr. Glasses is always announcing stuff like, "It's that kind of personal service that sets your store apart from Blockbuster." The over-friendliness itself is sort of creepy, as is the way he sort of doesn't blink enough and doesn't know that most business transactions don't really involve sustained eye contact. But I know that he's just trying his hardest, in his own mutant way, to be friendly.
“橙色帽子先生”是一名注册护士，当另一位顾客对我发脾气时，他跳出来为我辩护。“眼镜先生”总是宣布诸如“正是这种个性化的服务让你们的店从百视达中脱颖而出”之类的话。这种过度友善本身就有点令人毛骨悚然，就像他那种眨眼不够多，而且不知道大多数商业交易并不真正涉及持续眼神接触的方式一样。但我知道他只是在用他自己那种变异的方式，竭尽全力地表现友好。
Mr. Creaky was old and feeble but would rent a stack of disturbingly violent cartoon porn from Japan at least once a week. He always had the same patter as he came up to the register, "Do you watch that show, The Sopranos ?"
“吱呀先生”又老又虚弱，但每周至少会租一堆来自日本的令人不安的暴力卡通色情片。他走到收银台前总是说同样的话：“你看那个节目《黑道家族》吗？”
"No, sir."
“不，先生。”
"I hear it's pretty good."
“我听说它挺不错的。”
"Yes, sir. That's what I hear too."
“是的，先生。我也听说过。”
"I'd like to watch that show but I can't. There's too much cussing."
“我想看那个节目，但我看不了。里面脏话太多了。”
And then, clever ruse in place, he would put in his request for Demon Beast .
然后，巧妙的借口到位后，他会提出对《恶魔兽》的要求。
There is an interesting phenomenon that I've witnessed happen over and over again in the store. I call it the porn trance. We have two rooms of floor to ceiling boxes. People in the porn trance methodically look at every single one in their section. I see people look at box after box for two hours at a stretch all the time, and three hours is not uncommon. They don't hear announcements over the "Voice of God" microphone until you get drastic.
我曾在店里目睹过一个有趣的现象反复发生。我称之为“色情恍惚”。我们有两个房间，放着从地板到天花板的盒子。陷入色情恍惚的人会系统地查看他们那一区的每一个盒子。我经常看到人们连续两个小时看一个又一个盒子，看三个小时也不罕见。除非你采取激烈措施，否则他们听不到“上帝之声”麦克风里的公告。
"You in the red jacket with the baseball cap, you-- we're closing. Bring up your movies right now or you don't get to rent anything at all."
“那个戴棒球帽、穿红夹克的人，你——我们要关门了。现在把你的电影拿过来，否则你什么都租不到。”
Lone porn renters go into the trance almost immediately and resent being pulled out. Couples do not go into porn trance. There has already been a great deal of negotiating in getting both parties down there together. If either partner gets even a tiny fraction more interested in a porn star body than the other, the delicate balance-- and quite possibly the relationship-- is destroyed. For what it's worth, straight couples are rare in the porn section.
单独租色情片的人几乎立刻就会陷入恍惚，并反感被打断。情侣不会进入色情恍惚。两人一起下去已经经过了大量的谈判。如果任何一方对色情明星身材的兴趣哪怕比另一方多出一丁点，那种微妙的平衡——很可能还有这段关系——就会被破坏。不管怎样，异性恋情侣在色情区很少见。
Group renters never intend to go into the porn trance. They start out laughing together, pointing at the boxes and reading particularly ludicrous copy out loud. And then one by one they see something that really strikes them. And one by one, they get sucked in until the porn section is quiet again.
团体租赁者从没打算进入色情恍惚。他们开始时一起大笑，指着盒子，大声读出特别可笑的拷贝说明。然后一个接一个，他们看到了真正吸引他们的东西。一个接一个，他们被吸了进去，直到色情区再次安静下来。
Our store is deliberately designed to make the porn section hard to get to. We want people to have to pass the register so the clerk can see them. And we make them snake through the shelves a bit so it's hard for kids to get down there. Turns out, though, it was a nearly impossible gauntlet for a wheelchair. The guy in the wheelchair was surprisingly nice about it. This guy had to wait more than an hour for a special cab to pick him up. Then he had to get over our doorstep, which is wheelchair accessible in a theoretical sense at best, and weave his way through two tight aisles and around three corners.
我们的店故意设计得让色情区难以进入。我们希望人们必须经过收银台，这样店员能看到他们。我们让他们在货架间蜿蜒走一段，这样孩子们就很难下去。不过事实证明，这对轮椅来说几乎是不可能的挑战。那个坐轮椅的家伙对此出奇地友好。这家伙等了一个多小时才等到一辆特殊出租车来接他。然后他得越过我们的门槛——轮椅通道在理论上勉强可行——并在两条窄过道间穿行，绕过三个弯角。
The first path he tried ended up being too narrow and he got stuck and had to back up and try another route. And then, after all that, he hit a staircase. Luckily, he could walk a bit. He took the railing with one hand and my arm in the other and we went down. Then I went back and brought the chair down for him. I was torn between sticking around to help and giving the poor guy some privacy. I went with moderate privacy, leaving him alone and checking out the security camera every now and then until it looked like he was done, then going down to help him back up. And then he had to wait over an hour yet again for another taxi, which never showed.
他尝试的第一条路太窄了，他被卡住了，不得不倒退尝试另一条路线。然后，在那之后，他遇到了一排楼梯。幸运的是，他能走几步。他一只手扶着栏杆，另一只手扶着我的胳膊，我们下去了。然后我回去帮他把轮椅拿下来。我徘徊在留下来帮忙还是给这可怜的家伙一些隐私之间。我选择了适度的隐私，让他一个人呆着，不时查看监控摄像头，直到看起来他看完了，然后下去帮他上来。然后他又得再等一个多小时等另一辆出租车，结果没来。
We finally hailed him one, and a friend of mine helped me help him into the cab, bringing the total number of people who had helpfully intruded on his porn rental to six. I think the whole trip took him about four hours. Except to return the videos he hasn't been back. And I can't say I blame him. To do what most of our customers do with complete privacy and no thought, took him four humiliating hours.
我们最终为他拦了一辆，我的一个朋友帮我把他扶进出租车，使帮倒忙打断他租片的人数增加到了六个。我想整趟行程大概花了他四个小时。除了还录像带，他没再来过。我不能怪他。为了做大多数顾客在完全隐私、不用动脑的情况下就能做的事，他花了四个屈辱的小时。
Before he came in, I didn't think of the ability to rent porn with speed and discretion as a basic human right, but now I sort of do. It's stupid, but I do still feel an odd swell of pride about what I'm doing every now and then. Immigrants from repressed nations sign up for memberships, go downstairs, and for the first time in their lives see porn. Elderly gay men suddenly have an outlet. Guys who have had a rough day at the office are going to have a relaxing evening, if not a quiet one. If I make it to the security monitor in time, I can see their faces light up.
在他来之前，我并不认为能快速、谨慎地租到色情片是一项基本人权，但现在我多少有点这么觉得了。这很蠢，但我确实偶尔会对我在做的事情产生一种奇怪的自豪感。来自压抑国家的移民注册会员，走下楼，第一次在他们生命中看到了色情片。年长的同性恋男性突然有了出口。在办公室度过艰难一天的家伙们将有一个放松的夜晚，即使不是安静的一个。如果我及时赶到监控器前，我能看到他们脸上焕发出的光芒。
Ali Davis. When she's not doing her day job, she is in the improv troop, Baby Wants Candy, which does an improvised musical every Friday and Saturday night at the Improv Olympic Theater in Chicago.
阿里·戴维斯。当她不忙于日常工作时，她是即兴表演团“宝贝想要糖果”的成员，该团每周五和周六晚上在芝加哥即兴奥林匹克剧院进行即兴音乐剧表演。
Act Five, What Daddy Wants. A family is a complicated ecosystem when it comes to giving people what they want. Often, as with any gift, people give each other the things that they would want themselves. Curtis Sittenfeld has seen it all at work in her own family.
第五幕，《爸爸想要什么》。在满足人们需求方面，家庭是一个复杂的生态系统。通常，像对待任何礼物一样，人们给对方他们自己想要的东西。柯蒂斯·西滕费尔德在她自己的家里看到了这一切的运作。
In January, 1999, under the supervision of doctors, my father began a liquid diet. For five months, he ate no solid food and all he drank were chocolate flavored protein shakes. It was exciting and disorienting to see how rapidly a thinner, quicker, younger-seeming man emerged from inside my father's padding. The diet loomed so large in all our lives that my sister, Tiernan and I dreamt about it regularly.
1999年1月，在医生的监督下，我父亲开始尝试液体饮食。五个月里，他没吃任何固体食物，只喝巧克力味的蛋白质奶昔。看到一个更瘦、更快、更年轻的父亲从他臃肿的身体里显露出来，真是令人兴奋又迷茫。这个饮食计划在我们所有人的生活中占据了如此大的分量，以至于我妹妹蒂尔南和我经常梦见它。
By June, my dad had lost more than 100 pounds and it was time to switch to normal food. Within a year and a half, he gained back all the weight. It seems like my father has tried every weight-loss scheme there is. He's done 12-step programs and hypnosis, and one diet that consisted of eating all bananas one day, all tuna fish the next, and so on.
到了6月，我父亲瘦了100多磅，该转为正常饮食了。一年半之内，他把减掉的体重又全长了回来。看起来我父亲尝试过每一种减肥计划。他参加过12步计划、催眠疗法，还有一种饮食计划，内容是一天只吃香蕉，第二天只吃金枪鱼，以此类推。
Early last winter, my father called to tell me he was tackling his weight problem once again. After all the diets in the past, I was skeptical. But this plan sounded a little different. He had been referred to a woman known around Cincinnati as "The Diet Nazi." For reasons that are too complicated to go into, this woman has asked me not to use her real name. Or more precisely, she told me if I did, she'd slit my throat. Therefore, I am calling her Doris.
去年初冬，我父亲打电话告诉我，他又要解决体重问题了。考虑到过去的种种减肥经历，我持怀疑态度。但这个计划听起来有点不同。他被介绍给了一位在辛辛那提被称为“减肥纳粹”的女士。由于一些太复杂而不便细说的原因，这位女士要求我不要使用她的真名。更准确地说，她告诉如果我用了，她就割断我的喉咙。因此，我叫她多丽丝。
As my father explained to me, Doris is not a nutritionist, not a physical trainer, and not a therapist. She's a 68-year-old woman who lost 160 pounds on her own, 35 years ago and ever since then has been helping other people who are seriously overweight. She tells them exactly what they can and can't eat, down to the quantity and brand, and how much they should exercise. She also requires them to call her every night and come to her house to weigh in once a week. Basically, she's a nag for hire.
正如我父亲向我解释的那样，多丽丝不是营养学家，不是健身教练，也不是治疗师。她是一位68岁的女士，35年前自己瘦了160磅，从那以后一直在帮助其他严重超重的人。她准确地告诉他们能吃什么不能吃什么，细致到数量和品牌，以及应该做多少运动。她还要求他们每天晚上打电话给她，每周一次去她家称重。基本上，她是一个有偿的唠叨者。
All right, so Paul, you did everything I told you last week?
好了，保罗，上周我让你做的一切你都做了吗？
I haven't been exercising twice a day, I've been exercising once a day.
我没能每天运动两次，我每天只运动了一次。
That's not good. You've got to give up some of your workload--
那可不好。你得放弃一些工作量——
My father and Doris are meeting, as they do every week, in the living room of the suburban house she shares with her husband. Doris sees all her clients in individual meetings on Thursdays. So in the morning, she brings out a scale and sets it on a special white square of carpet.
我父亲和多丽丝像每周一样，在她与丈夫居住的郊区房子的客厅里见面。多丽丝在周四一对一地接待所有客户。所以早上，她拿出秤，放在一块特殊的白色地毯方块上。
Is your choice still the flakes in the morning?
你早上还是选择吃麦片吗？
Yes, I've been having that. The flakes, some Grape-Nuts, a banana, and skim milk.
是的，我一直在吃。麦片、一些葡萄坚果、一根香蕉和脱脂牛奶。
OK, you could also have oatmeal.
OK，你也可以吃燕麦片。
I don't like oatmeal.
我不喜欢燕麦片。
OK, do you like egg whites?
OK，你喜欢蛋白吗？
With yolks.
带蛋黄的。
No, not with the yolks.
不，不能带蛋黄。
No.
不。
You can have three egg whites with some green pepper and some--
你可以吃三个蛋白，配上一些青椒和一些——
I hate green pepper. It makes me belch.
我讨厌青椒。它让我打嗝。
Well, that's too bad. What you hate is good for you.
好吧，那太遗憾了。你讨厌的东西对你有好处。
The first time my dad met Doris, she greeted him at the door wearing a Snoopy night shirt and no shoes. At the time, my dad was afraid she'd forgotten he was coming over. Later, he learned that she always wears night shirts when she sees clients.
我父亲第一次见多丽丝时，她穿着史努比睡衣，光着脚在门口迎接他。当时，我父亲担心她忘了自己要来。后来，他才知道她见客户时总是穿睡衣。
You have your bottles and make sure you get your gallon to gallon and a half of water down a day.
你要带好你的瓶子，确保每天喝下一加仑到一加仑半的水。
That I've been doing. In fact, I may have an accident sitting here.
那个我一直在做。事实上，坐在这里我可能就要出事故了。
Well, that's OK, I'll help you up.
好吧，没关系，我会帮你起来。
When my dad started seeing Doris, the thing that excited me was the fact that he seemed intimidated by her. Finally, here was someone who would stand up to him. One night, my dad called Doris for his mandatory check-in and he confessed to her that he hadn't had the chance to exercise that day. "Bullshit to that," Dorris cried. "Put on your shoes and go to the gym right now." The amazing part was that my father obeyed her. He changed his clothes and drove to the gym with my sister Josephine and me. In his first month working with Doris, even though it was the holiday season, my father lost 14 pounds.
我父亲开始见多丽丝时，让我兴奋的是他似乎对她感到畏惧。终于，这里有一个敢于对抗他的人了。一天晚上，父亲打电话给多丽丝进行强制签到，他坦白说自己那天没机会运动。“胡说八道，”多丽丝大喊，“穿上你的鞋子，现在就去健身房。”惊人的是，我父亲听从了她。他换上衣服，和我的妹妹约瑟芬以及我一起去了健身房。在和多丽丝合作的第一个月，尽管那是节日期间，我父亲还是减掉了14磅。
This might be an appropriate place for me to tell you that I don't know exactly how much father weighs, and I don't want to know. What I can tell you is this: he's 5'11" and he said recently that if he lost 150 pounds he would not be excessively thin. In a way, the fact that my dad struggles with his weight is utterly ordinary. It often seems like the majority of Americans are either obese or on a diet or both. But my father's weight problem never feels ordinary to me. Instead, it feels sad and specific and incredibly complicated.
在这里我可能应该告诉你们，我不知道父亲具体体重是多少，我也不想知道。我可以告诉你们的是：他身高5英尺11英寸，他最近说如果瘦掉150磅，他也不会显得过于消瘦。在某种程度上，父亲与体重的抗争显得非常平凡。似乎大多数美国人要么肥胖，要么正在节食，或者两者兼有。但我父亲的体重问题对我来说从不平凡。相反，它让我感到悲伤、具体且极其复杂。
The part I feel most confused by is what my role in the situation should be. When I try to get my father to eat better, is it an act of love or is it just nagging? And if it's nagging, isn't it justified when so much is at stake? Not only does my dad face serious health risks like a heart attack or stroke, but he also has trouble with his back, gets cramps in his legs, and is easily winded. He also sleep apnea, which means that to regulate his breathing at night, he uses what looks like a beige scuba mask attached by a tube to an air machine.
让我感到最困惑的部分是，在这个处境中我的角色应该是什么。当我试图让父亲吃得更好时，这是一种爱的行为，还是仅仅是唠叨？如果这是唠叨，当风险如此之大时，难道不是正当的吗？父亲不仅面临心脏病发作或中风等严重的健康风险，而且背部也有问题，腿部会抽筋，而且很容易喘不过气。他还有睡眠呼吸暂停，这意味着为了在夜间调节呼吸，他必须使用看起来像连接着空气机的米色水肺面具。
All of this would be enough to make me worry, but I also am bothered by something else. When people meet my father for the first time, I'm afraid that all they see is a fat man. You know when you're on a plane and you see an obese guy heading down the aisle and you're hoping he isn't coming for the seat next to yours, and then he does stop at your row and he sits down beside you and maybe he needs to ask the flight attendant for a seat belt extension, and you're either cringing or trying not to cringe as he spills over the armrest into your space. I don't like it that the man you're having those feelings about is my father.
所有这些足以让我担心，但我还受另一件事的困扰。当人们第一次见到我父亲时，我害怕他们看到的只是一个胖子。你知道当你坐在飞机上，看到一个肥胖的家伙正沿着过道走来，你希望他不是要坐你旁边，然后他停在你那排，坐在你身边，也许他需要向空乘要安全带延长器，而你或是瑟缩，或是试图不瑟缩，因为他溢过了扶手侵占了你的空间。我不喜欢那种让你有这种感觉的男人是我父亲。
[SINGING IN OPERA STYLE]
[歌剧风格演唱]
Here's my dad on a typical evening at home. He's sitting at the kitchen table opening the mail while my mom cooks dinner. Even if my dad weren't big, he'd stand out. He's loud and he likes to tell jokes and stories. He genuinely loves doing things for other people. He'll invite you over for dinner if he suspects you're lonely or take soup to you when you're sick. He's a volunteer on about 15 boards, which is actually fewer than he used to be on. And he works as an investment adviser. He's incredibly busy, which is one reason he eats too much.
这是我父亲在家里的典型夜晚。他坐在厨房桌旁看邮件，妈妈在做饭。即使我父亲不胖，他也会很显眼。他声音大，喜欢讲笑话和故事。他真心喜欢为别人做事。如果他觉得你很孤独，他会邀请你来吃晚饭，或者当你生病时送汤给你。他在大约15个董事会担任志愿者，这实际上比他过去担任的还要少。他是一名投资顾问。他非常忙碌，这是他吃太多的原因之一。
It's a coping mechanism. And I guess it's when somebody else would take a drink, smoke a cigarette, kick at the cat, whatever kind of not very productive and wholly irrelevant response. This is nothing that I pre-plan.
这是一种应对机制。我想当别人想喝酒、抽烟、踢猫时，无论那是什么样的一种不是很有建设性且完全不相关的反应。这不是我预先计划好的任何事情。
My family members deal with my dad's weight in different ways. The one person who never nags him is my mother, who is perpetually optimistic. My father appreciates this.
我的家庭成员以不同的方式对待父亲的体重。我母亲从不唠叨他，她总是保持乐观。我父亲很欣赏这一点。
If I've been dieting, she'll say-- within the first three or four hours-- I think you're already beginning to look a little bit thinner. My two sisters ask about my dad's diets and exercise, but they don't push it. My brother P.G. and I are considered the confrontational ones. It especially gets under our skin when my dad kids himself about what he's eating.
如果我在节食，她会说——在最初的三个或四个小时内——我想你已经开始看起来瘦一点了。我的两个姐妹会询问父亲的饮食和运动，但她们不会催促。我哥哥P.G.和我被认为是爱挑衅的那种人。当父亲对自己吃的东西自欺欺人时，我们特别不爽。
You can't knock someone when they believe something's true. It's kind of like, well, OK, I'm not going to have rib roast for lunch. I'm having lobster. It came from the sea. And it's this natural food. But when you dip it in a mayonnaise sauce, it's like, I'm having lobster and half a jar of mayonnaise. And that's not so healthy anymore.
当一个人相信某件事是真的时，你无法反驳他。这就像，好吧，我不吃肋排肉做午餐。我吃龙虾。它是来自海洋的。这是天然食物。但当你把它浸在蛋黄酱里时，就像是，我吃着龙虾和半罐蛋黄酱。那就不那么健康了。
Recently, we went out for breakfast and P.G. and my dad got into it.
最近，我们出去吃早餐，P.G.和父亲发生了争执。
Here is a 55-year-old man in his own kitchen. I go to get something out of the ice box and P.G.-- what is he, 17 years old-- says, I'm going to call Curtis. He calls his 26-year-old sister in Iowa to tell her that I've been eating-- it's like I've been stealing money or snorting cocaine.
这是一个55岁的男人在他自己的厨房里。我从冰柜里拿点东西，P.G.——他才17岁——说，我要打电话给柯蒂斯。他给在爱荷华州的26岁姐姐打电话，告诉她我一直在吃——就像我一直在偷钱或者吸食可卡因一样。
All right. Let me put this story in context. The way things went down is that this was after he'd just gotten home from dinner and he decided he wanted to have some Parmesan walnut spread. Right after dinner.
好了。让我把这个故事放在语境中。事情是这样的，那是在他刚吃完晚饭后，他决定要吃点帕尔马干酪核桃酱。就在晚饭后。
It's none of your business.
不关你的事。
Actually, I feel like it is our business, like my father has made it our business for my whole life. I remember going to the track with my dad and my sister Tiernan when I was six or seven, to walk with him in the morning. Even then I knew two things: that the goal was for him to lose weight and that I was part of a larger family campaign to make it happen.
事实上，我觉得这就是我们的事，我父亲一生都把这变成了我们的事。我记得在我六七岁时，和父亲以及妹妹蒂尔南去赛马场，早晨陪他散步。那时我就知道两件事：目标是他减肥，而我是实现这一目标的大型家庭运动的一部分。
And where are we going for lunch?
午餐我们去哪吃？
What do you want to eat? You want to go to the Cactus Pear?
你想吃什么？你想去仙人掌梨餐厅吗？
I feel like Cactus Pear might--
我觉得仙人掌梨可能——
Taste delicious?
味道很好吃？
It might-- would you get that cheese and shrimp thing?
它可能——你会点那个奶酪和虾的菜吗？
Sure.
当然。
My dad and I are driving around doing errands when the subject of lunch comes up. In my family, the cheese and shrimp dish at Cactus Pear is somewhat legendary. And I'm not sure if I was asking my father if he would get it because it's oily and I didn't want him to, or because it tastes wonderful and I was hoping he'd share it with me. This is the major conflict I feel about my dad's weight. I hate the fact that he's so heavy and I love eating with him. In situations like this one, I try to put us on the right track. But maybe I don't try as hard as I could.
父亲和我在办差事，午餐的话题就出现了。在我们家，仙人掌梨餐厅的奶酪虾菜品是相当传奇的。我不确定我是因为这道菜油腻不想让他吃而问他，还是因为这味道太棒了，我希望他能和我分享。这就是我对自己父亲体重的重大冲突感受。我讨厌他这么胖，我又喜欢和他一起吃饭。在这种情况下，我试图让他走上正轨。但我可能没试过我能做到的那么努力。
Actually, I wonder if there's a Bob Evans. There's a delicious salad I had at Bob Evans.
其实，我想知道有没有鲍勃·埃文斯餐厅。我在鲍勃·埃文斯吃过一种美味的沙拉。
If it's a truly healthy salad, I'll go. But if it's a fake healthy salad with like--
如果它是真正健康的沙拉，我会去的。但如果它是那种虚假健康的沙拉，比如——
It has red onions, fresh pineapple, fresh strawberries, grilled chicken, different kind of salad greens, blue cheese, did I say that?
它有红洋葱、新鲜菠萝、新鲜草莓、烤鸡、不同的沙拉菜，蓝纹奶酪，我说了吗？
What ended up happening was a worst case scenario. We went to an Indian buffet. You know the phrase, all you can eat? Well, my family takes it literally. Recently, I told my brother P.G. that I thought the definition of a good meal was when you had to unbutton your pants afterward. P.G. said he thought it was when your pants unbutton themselves. And this is my family's dirty little secret. For us, eating is practically a sport. We bribe each other with food, and we definitely compete over food. Here's my brother, PG.
结果发生的情况是最糟糕的剧本。我们去了一家印度自助餐厅。你知道那句话，“无限量供应”吗？好吧，我的家人对此是照字面意思理解的。最近，我告诉哥哥P.G.，我认为一顿美餐的定义是吃完后不得不解开裤子。P.G.说他认为那是裤子自己崩开的时候。这是我们家不为人知的小秘密。对我们来说，吃饭几乎是一项运动。我们用食物贿赂彼此，我们也绝对在食物上竞争。这是我哥哥P.G.。
Sometimes-- and I feel like this is where Daddy is not necessarily far and away the most guilty-- sometimes Mommy will bring over a salad dressed and there will be a lot of avocado sitting on top and blue cheese. And there'll be this sixth sense among maybe-- let's just say you, me and daddy-- of like I need to get to that salad first so I can get all of the avocado.
有时——我觉得这是爸爸不一定是唯一负罪最重的地方——有时妈妈会带过来一份拌好的沙拉，上面会有很多牛油果和蓝纹奶酪。在那之后，比如——我们假设是你，我，爸爸——之间会有一种第六感，就是我需要先拿到那份沙拉，这样我能拿到所有的牛油果。
And when you're actually having a conversation with another family member, out of the eye in the back of your head you'll be checking out the salad bowl as another member of the family takes salad from it, to make sure they're not taking too much avocado. And if they do, you'll definitely call them on it.
当你实际上在和其他家庭成员交谈时，你的后脑勺眼睛会盯着沙拉碗，看其他家人是否在取沙拉，确保他们没拿太多牛油果。如果他们拿了，你绝对会指出来。
When we're not consuming a meal, we're probably planning when we next will or holding a postmortem on a meal we just finished, deconstructing it course by course. Which brings us to the really tough question about my father's weight: how can our favorite activity, the thing that truly brings us together as a family, be so wrong? Sometimes I think we should just give in to what makes my father happy.
当我们不吃饭时，我们可能在计划下一次什么时候吃，或者对刚刚吃完的一顿饭进行尸检，逐道菜进行拆解。这就引出了关于父亲体重的一个非常棘手的问题：我们最喜欢的活动，那个真正让全家人聚在一起的事情，怎么会是如此错误呢？有时我觉得我们应该满足父亲让他快乐的事情。
I do. I had a good day and I ate carefully all the way through. I had a little bit of turkey for lunch. I had cereal for breakfast and a banana. I had lots of water. I exercised. And I had salad for dinner.
我确实满足了。我有过美好的一天，我一直很小心地吃。我午饭只吃了一点火鸡肉。早饭喝了谷物粥和一根香蕉。喝了很多水。我运动了。晚餐吃了沙拉。
Before bed, my dad makes his nightly call to Doris. When he first met Doris, she told him if he missed a night she'd call him first thing the next morning and wake up the whole family.
睡觉前，父亲给多丽丝打每晚的电话。第一次见到多丽丝时，她告诉他如果漏了一晚，她第二天一早就会打给他，叫醒全家人。
The market? You pay too much attention. Just get me thin and stop worrying. I know. We'll talk tomorrow. Take care. Bye.
市场？你关注得太多了。只要让我变瘦，别再操心了。我知道。我们明天谈。保重。再见。
So I think a good starting place might be the fact that I feel like you just totally glossed over what you ate today. Like when you said that you had a salad for dinner, it had blue cheese in it, or that it was what I would describe as generously dressed.
所以我认为一个好的出发点可能是，我觉得你完全敷衍了你今天吃的东西。比如你说晚餐吃了沙拉，里面有蓝纹奶酪，或者说那是我描述的“大方地加了调料”的那种。
Well, I didn't do the dressing. Yeah, I would say it was not a particularly dietetic salad. But what I think probably-- and that's of course, part of the issue-- that I am not altogether realistic about portions. But I would guess, essentially to think about it, that I think I had less than one ounce of blue cheese. Now that's more than no blue cheese. But it's not like eating-- which I could also have done-- eight ounces of blue cheese.
嗯，我没放调料。是啊，我会说那不是一份特别符合饮食要求的沙拉。但我想可能——这当然是问题的一部分——我对分量并不完全现实。但我猜，从本质上讲，我想我吃的蓝纹奶酪不到一盎司。那比没有蓝纹奶酪多。但那不像吃——我也本可以做到——八盎司蓝纹奶酪。
Of course, I also didn't mention what I had at the reception I went to at 5 o'clock today. I hadn't thought about that. They had really quite big, delicious shrimp. And it was a fellow's retirement party, so I figured he wouldn't be retiring again probably. So I had several shrimp. But again, I didn't have any mayonnaise or anything like that, I just used cocktail sauce, which is basically ketchup and horseradish.
当然，我也没提我今天下午5点在招待会上吃的东西。我没考虑过那个。他们有非常大、非常好吃的虾。这是一个人的退休派对，所以我想他大概不会再退休了。所以我吃了几只虾。但同样，我没加蛋黄酱之类的，我只用了鸡尾酒酱，基本上就是番茄酱和辣根。
See, I've got a whole ability to rationalize, to deal with any-- I probably ate about 12 large shrimp. I mean, they weren't as big as your fist. But they were certainly-- they were not shrimpy shrimp. And maybe there were a few more than 12. Maybe it was 14 or 16.
你看，我完全有能力合理化，来应付任何——我可能吃了大约12只大虾。我是说，它们不像拳头那么大。但它们确实——它们不是小虾米。可能比12只多一点。可能是14或16只。
My dad has been meeting with Doris for seven months now. And these days, even she's showing signs of discouragement. She must know he's not following her recommendations. And I'm guessing she knows he doesn't tell her the whole truth about what he eats. After losing and gaining several times, my father is down a total of 12 pounds, which is two pounds less than he'd lost in the first month with her. Recently, she told my father that because she attracts clients through word of mouth, the fact that he's lost so little weight makes him a bad advertisement for her services.
父亲见多丽丝已经七个月了。这些日子，连她也表现出灰心的迹象。她肯定知道他没遵循她的建议。而且我猜她知道他没告诉她关于吃东西的全部真相。在经历了多次增减体重后，父亲总共瘦了12磅，比他刚开始和她合作的第一个月瘦的还少了2磅。最近，她告诉父亲，因为她是靠口碑吸引客户的，所以他瘦得这么少使他成了她服务的糟糕广告。
The situation is basically impossible because all of us want such contradictory things. My dad wants us to leave him alone and he wants to please us. My siblings and I want him to be healthy and we want him to enjoy the food he loves. At every level, our wishes conflict. No wonder he continues to pay Doris, even though she gives him advice that he doesn't take. She's a kind of inoculation against the rest of us. He can point to her and say, look I'm trying, now leave me alone. By seeing Doris, he's giving us what we want. And I think that's what he wants most of all, maybe even more than he wants to lose weight.
这种情况基本上是不可能的，因为我们所有人想要的东西都是如此相互矛盾。爸爸想让我们别管他，他又想取悦我们。我和我姐妹们想让他健康，又想让他享受他喜爱的食物。在每一个层面上，我们的愿望都在冲突。难怪他继续付钱给多丽丝，尽管她给他的建议他根本不听。她是针对我们其余人的一种“接种”。他可以指着她说，看我正在尝试，现在别管我了。通过见多丽丝，他是在给我们想要的东西。我想那正是他最想要的，也许比他想减肥还要多。
Curtis Sittenfeld.
柯蒂斯·西滕费尔德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our production manager, Todd Bachmann, invited me to the Alzheimer's wedding and did some of the interviews there. You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的制作经理托德·巴克曼邀请我去参加了阿尔茨海默症婚礼，并在那里做了一些采访。你知道你可以从audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wants you to remember just one thing from today's program. Please, just one thing.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他希望你记住今天节目中的一件事。求你了，就记住一件事。
Martin Waldseemuller.
马丁·瓦尔德塞米勒。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周继续为您带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
P R I, Public Radio International.
P R I，国际公共广播电台。